Speaker 1: I hope everybody had a good Memorial
Day long weekend if you had one.
I actually had an anti-Semitic incident over
the weekend, someone hurling anti-Semitic
abuse at me on the street.
I will tell you that story later in the show.
But I also came back from the break to realize
that the treasonous and seditious tentacles
of the Trump administration continue to grow
and spread.
Donald Trump's indicted and pardoned former
national security adviser Michael Flynn has
been caught on video saying that a coup like
what happened in Myanmar should happen in
the United States, presumably against the
Joe Biden administration.
Now, this is not some random kuhnen shaman
wearing a weird hat saying it.
This is a former national security adviser
to the president of the United States, Flynn
said this Sunday night during a Q&A session
at a conference called the For God and Country
Patriot Round up in Dallas, Texas.
There is a little detail here that is just
perfect, which is that the person asking Flynn
the question doesn't even know that it's Myanmar.
Instead, he says, M.R., like every detail,
is hairbrained.
The focus is Flynn's answer, of course.
But even the question is just you couldn't
write this stuff.
Speaker 2: A simple Marine, I want to know
why what happened in Miramar can't happen
here.
Speaker 3: You know, the reason that I know
this should have one more.
Speaker 1: It should happen here, says a former
national security adviser to a president of
the United States.
What happened in Myanmar or M.R.?
As he said, a coup in Myanmar started on the
morning of February 1st this year when democratically
elected members of the country's ruling party,
the National League for Democracy, were thrown
out.
They were deposed by the Tatmadaw Myanmar's
military, which then vested power in a strategy
ocracy.
And the country's military executed a morning
raid.
They detained the elected leader, Aung San
Suu Kyi, and other political figures.
The military said what we did is right because
there was voter fraud allegation in the Myanmar
November election.
So the link is, of course, the analogy they
claim exists with voter fraud, stealing the
election from Donald Trump in our November
of twenty twenty election, which they therefore
used to justify what Michael Flynn says there
should be a coup and Joe Biden should be deposed,
should be forcibly removed from the White
House.
Now, remember that these are the very people,
the loudest ones, screaming about how they
are patriots.
They have no actual respect for the Constitution.
However, they are the loudest one.
Screaming about we are for the rule of law
must be law and order.
But they have no respect for the rule of law.
They are attacking us from within.
Now, as a practical question, is this beyond
the limits of free speech because it's an
incitement to violence, a retired general
that is so clearly a traitor and there is
a key difference here between the modern left
and the modern right.
And it's important to talk about and when
when there are similar, when you can't tell
the difference between left and right, we
pointed out.
But we're left and right, couldn't be more
different.
We also point that out when the people I vote
for lose an election, I don't like it, but
I don't say let's overthrow the government
even when for years, the Russia probe looked
at whether Donald Trump was helped by a foreign
power in 2016.
All of that stuff, the left wasn't saying,
let's do a violent insurrection to remove
Donald Trump.
And by the way, as far as Flint goes, who
is even paying Michael Flynn now?
Is he does he have a pension from the military?
If so, shouldn't this lead to you losing your
pension?
Is he getting paid for these one off appearances?
Is someone funding what he's doing?
And who even would want to do that at this
point in time?
Not the best people, that's for sure.
And this is why downplaying January 6th is
so dangerous.
If you downplay the importance of January
6th, it makes escalation more likely.
It welcomes the escalation.
And when you hear a statement like this from
Michael Flynn, it shows that Republicans have
truly learned nothing from the January 6th
Trump riots.
And not only that, it's actually an escalation
of rhetoric and it's hard to know what what
what the the right really sees as the next
step here with this stuff.
And in a sense, what Republicans have learned
from January 6th so far, because, you know,
look look at what's taking place.
So far, they've learned that nobody's really
going to stop them.
And it's not even clear there will be consequences
if they do another version of January 6th.
So now the trend that we're seeing is those
who have claimed for years to be about law
and order and those who for years have pointed
fingers at antifa and black lives matter and
ecoterrorists and the violent left or whatever
the case may be.
Those are the people who now are regularly
calling for violence over the last few weeks.
And I want to take a moment and look at that
trend now with this additional example of
Trump's former national security adviser,
Michael Flynn